هنا معي الآن ، رئيس
فنلندا ، شاول أولي نينستا ، السيد الرئيس ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على الانضمام إلي مرة أخرى
وقبل أيام فقط من غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا ،
تحدثنا وأخبرتني أنك
لا ترى أي سبب لاقتباس
تغييرات مفاجئة مفاجئة في علاقة فنلندا
بحلف الناتو.  ها نحن بعد ثلاثة أشهر
فقط وقد أعلنت للتو
أنك ستتقدم رسميًا للانضمام إلى تحالف الناتو ،
لأنك قلق من
أن روسيا قد تهاجمك أيضًا
ليس بالضرورة ولكن هناك شيئان يجب أن تضعهما في
المرتبة
الأولى
حاولت روسيا إنكارهما  أي توسع في
حلف الناتو
وقد تغير بطريقة ما إلى حد كبير
موقفنا هنا
حتى الآن ، كنا نظن أنه حسنًا ،
نحن غير منحازين لإرادتنا
ولكن عندما قالوا أن
هذا يعني أنه ليس لدينا أي
إرادة متبقية
لذلك كان  المرحلة الأولى وبالتأكيد في
الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير عندما
قاموا بهجوم ضخم على أوكرانيا والذي
تغير كثيرًا
، أظهر أنهم مستعدون
للهجوم على دولة مجاورة مستقلة
لذلك كنت قلقًا  د أنه يمكن أن
تتعرض للهجوم
ليس بالضرورة ،
لكنني أقول إن
الأشياء كانت تتغير أيضًا
بلا شك ، وما نراه الآن
أوروبا ، فإن العالم أكثر انقسامًا
لا يوجد مجال
كبير لعدم
الانحياز بينهما ،
لذا كان هذا أيضًا ما كنا نفكر فيه.
لا أعتقد أنهم لم يخططوا
لأي هجوم على فنلندا
ليس في ذلك الوقت ولا الآن